When they make a movie
out of this podcast,
Tom Hanks will play you.
Yeah, you're a hero.
That's right.
Hey, wasn't he nice on
the podcast the other day?
[Sona] Oh, I love him so much.
Isn't he the best?
He's the nicest guy.
And people always say that.
I'm telling you, I've known him since 1988
And I've I've spent, you know,
when you add up all the time
that I've been around him,
I've only see him be a gracious,
really nice, fascinating guy.
Very funny, very smart.
Do you know that when
you guys were talking
about World War II, I would never do this.
I would never interrupt,
but I wanted to talk.
Just, I love talking about that stuff.
And I was just drooling while you guys
were talking about that.
Yeah.
No, I'm glad you didn't jump in.
[Matt] No, I know you're glad.
(Sona giggles)
No, but you know what I mean.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, I would never.
I would never.
It's not.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, like,
but I could have listened to you guys
go on for hours about that.
No, when two icons of film are talking,
you don't, you just wanna let them go.
You're an icon of film?
Yeah, what?
I was cut out
of the Coneheads movie.
(laughing) What were you?
A conehead in the background.
That's a true story. (laughing)
Lorne Michaels,
I was out here--
Did you know
they removed you (laughing)
from the background?
Lorne Michaels wanted,
it was when he was talking to me
about doing the "Late Night" show,
and he wanted to have a meeting with me.
And then he just was like,
"Just I'll meet you at
Paramount or whatever."
And I went, okay.
And I went to Paramount, then he went,
"Just listen, you're at Paramount anyway.
"Just be in the background
of this Coneheads movie.
"We're making the Coneheads movie."
'Cause the best time to make
a movie about the Coneheads
is 25 years after it's been
(Matt laughs)
a huge hit on television.
But anyway, he said, "Just
be in the background."
And I went, you don't say no to Lorne.
And I went, okay.
"And then, you know, when
you're done doing that,
"we'll talk."
And so the next thing you know,
I'm in a trailer, and they're
putting a big cone on my head.
And then I walk out, and
those things are ridiculous.
They're really heavy.
And you can't maneuver.
And I'm tall anyway, I'm six-four,
but the cone made me about seven-four.
Oh my God.
Or seven-five.
And then I was like, oh
man, this is really painful.
I'm just gonna lie down.
And this person with a
headset and a clipboard said,
"Don't lie down!
"You can't lie down!
"You have to keep standing
until your scene is shot,
"because you'll ruin the cone."
And I'm literally, it's
like a crowd scene,
and I'm in the background.
You don't even know it's me.
And I'm thinking, "I just was here
"to talk to Lorne."
"Get over there and wait!
"And in 40 minutes, we'll throw
some ground chuck your way."
And so I'm I waiting.
And then I'm in the background,
and they go, okay, "Action!"
Literally there's, I mean,
I'm so far from the camera
that I can't even see the camera.
And I hear, you know, Dan Akroyd say,
"Yes, Blendar!
"No, Blendar!
(Sona giggles)
"Boo!"
And Jane curtain goes, "Boo!"
And they go "And cut!
"Okay, we'll do that one
more time in six hours.
"Everyone leave.
(Sona giggles)
"No one lie down."
(Matt laughs)
And then finally I shot the scene.
Of course they never used that scene!